hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the ftx crypto cup and this is the
first round
uh with the wrong name for wesley for
some reason
sorry about that
[Music]
there we go
good thing i caught that on on the first
second
all right so it's wesley saw versus
magnus carlsen and this is the first
game of their
uh final match of the ftx crypto cup and
the wesley has the white piece so it's
already a very exciting one
uh without further ado let's check out
what happened here so magnus uh
wesley has the white pieces and he opens
with e4
uh we have e5 knight to f3 knight to c6
and the bishop to c4 now we have bishop
to c5 and i know what you guys are
wondering will
the finals be where we finally see the
move uh
no it won't first wesley goes c3 yeah so
just a normal joke or piano the main
line with knight to f6
and now striking in the center with d4
uh we have e captures on d4 uh and now
e5
one of the oldest lines in chess we have
d5 attacking the bishop and bishop to b5
now
we have knight to e4 and now c captures
on d for attacking the bishop here
and now there are some games where
bishop to be for check is played but
black has much better results with
bishop to b6 so of course magnus goes
for that
knight to c3 and now we have castles by
magnus with bishop to e3
continuing development and the magnus
does the same bishop to g4 we have queen
to c2
unfinning now the knight can move and
bishop now to f5 now you're already
threatening a lot of very nasty stuff
like maybe knight to g3 attacking the
queen attacking the rook also defending
the bishop
so white needs to do something about
this and as
magnus lost the temple here by moving
the bishop twice wesley doesn't mind by
wasting a tempo by playing queen to b3
so here uh we have knights the e7
preparing to kick away the bishop with
c6 and here
at wesley castles we have c6 bishop back
to e2
and here magnus played rook to b8 and
it's a funny looking move but it comes
with the idea that if wesley attacks the
bishop with knight to a4 you can move
the bishop
and then the b7 pawn will be uh nicely
defended and the problem is
this is a completely new move so it has
never been played before or wesley
most likely encountering it for the
first time but magnus spent a lot of
time reaching this position
uh magnus is down to five minutes
already whereas wesley
uh basically the gains time he only
played on
uh by gaining incrementing he'll he has
uh 16 more minutes on the clock
uh so here wesley continues with knight
the a4 attacks the bishop here bishop to
c7
and now knights the h4 like we say
the knight on the rim is them but maybe
two knights are not
so here attacking the bishop here and
while magnus could go back
now if you go back you allow some f3
ideas then we have to play b5 then the
knight can go here so you can trade off
this guy
captures captures and then we play this
position magnus doesn't like this and he
plays
f6 now once again is this one of the
positions where f6 kind of ruins the
game for black
let's see what wesley plays and there
are a lot of options here which is not
surprising since this is a very well
prepared engine line for both
sides and uh trying to even analyze this
with conventional engines will only
uh you know get you get you so far so
here
uh obviously the e5 pawn is defended you
could uh you
attacked you could defend it with
something like f4 uh you could maybe
uh play f3 try to kick it away you could
play bishop to f3 you could play maybe
knights to c3 again go for this knight
here
and then maybe if captures captures then
we capture on e5 d
captures on e5 so we get this position
maybe f4 can be played later on
uh but uh either way all of this seems
perfectly fine
for both white and black however here
after f6 wesley played bishop to f3
and now comes uh well b5 chasing away
this knight
knight to c3 and only now magnus capture
so knight captures on c3
but wesley doesn't capture back instead
he plays e captures on f6 so he's going
for a
somewhat an adventurous line now magnus
being extremely low on time
uh probably had something to do with
that he wants to keep things complicated
as
wesley thrives in chaos uh if you've
seen in any of the previous games or
matches that he played
and here we have bishop to e4 so it's a
really
interesting idea uh you could also try
something like
queen to d6 this threatens mate in one
and after only after white defense this
then you pick up the pawn
uh with queen so while this is possible
then we'd see something like queen
captures on c3
bishop to h3 attacking the rook here and
after let's say bishop g2 captures
captures or maybe even better knight
captures we get this position
and then who knows what's happening but
magnus even though he's already down to
one minute on the clock he plays bishop
to e4 keeps all the tension
now both of his knights are hanging and
it's up to wesley to find the move here
wesley decides to capture the knight on
c3 and only now queen to d6
threatening checkmate we have g3 and now
magnus captures the bishop here we have
bishop captures on f3
and now should wesley capture back and
this is definitely a possibility then
magnus just wins the the f6 pawn and
then after knight to e5
it's a beautiful outpost for the knight
because you you never really want to
capture this with the bishop the bishop
is such a great piece here
if you capture this it doesn't really do
anything now if queen captures an a5 you
can capture on a7
then the material is equal not much not
much really to worry about here
so instead magnus goes uh after this um
sorry bishop to f3 we have bishop to f4
and i said fishing sug
by wesley attacking the queen now queen
captures on f6
and now bishop captures on c7 attacking
magnus's rook here we have rook to b7
and now bishop back to e5 with an attack
on the queen so queen to f7
uh and only now knight captures on f3
we have queen captures on f3 and now
comes queen to b4
and this is uh again already quite quite
an adventurous move
uh we have knights the f5 by magnus and
now
uh now the problem is that uh wasteless
queen on
on b4 isn't really doing anything and
here what wesley should
do is play queen back to b3 and then
maybe play something like c4
try and offer upon here to get a get a
queen trade in uh however wesley played
queen to c5 going after the c6 pawn but
now
this only uh well this only brings
trouble for him
because magnus here triples up on the f
file he plays rook b to f7
and now uh well what do you play here
wesley brings the rook into the game
rook a to e1 but now
h5 and that's the problem magnus doesn't
care about the c pawn he's just gonna
push this pawn open up the the king's
position or even better
get it to h3 and then deliver queen to
g2 checkmate there's really nothing you
can do about that
since you only have rooks and you have a
dark square bishop g2 is a light square
so here h3 uh wesley tries to prevent
this so now if magnus pushes h4 then
maybe he can do something in between but
not really magnus says
h4 i'm still just gonna play this uh
problem is g4 really just opens up the
white position too much so he doesn't uh
appreciate this he plays queen captures
on c6
uh but this is now even worse because
wesley saw one continuation but magnus
had a different one in mind
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
not going with the h pawn since this
only yields a draw at best
because if h captures on g3 you can
simply recapture and now there's
really no good move here but the bishop
covers this pawn and if you
do something like uh well let's say you
could
move the knight but then your queen gets
captured so best for black is to simply
play something like knight captures here
and offer a trade uh rook captures an f3
knight captures and c6
we can capture on f7 king captures and
we trade down into a very very simple
end game
so what the magnus did instead is not
capture with the h1 he played captures
with knight so congratulations to
everyone who found that
and now there really isn't anything
wesley can do here because if the knight
is captured then we have this beautiful
mate with a queen sacrifice queen
captures on f1 with
check and now you have to capture if q
if king goes to h2 rook f2 is checkmate
so you have to capture the queen but now
it's just rook captures an f1 check
king to g2 and now rook to f2 checkmate
so
that's probably what wesley missed uh so
he played bishop captures on g3 instead
but now just h captures and g3
and now there really isn't a good move
for white wesley tried rook to e8
maybe fend off one of the attackers but
just g2 by magnus the absolute quickest
way to win
and that's just it wesley traded here
once captures captures
and it was in this position on move 33
that wesley so resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh
why did he resign well you lose the rook
and you can't move the rook because
queen captures this uh
and adjust it after one check is given
you're just gonna hide your king and
that's it
uh if you move your rook anywhere it
doesn't really matter
we're just going to capture here with
check bring the king to
h2 and now play pawn to g1 and bring
anything
okay it's the best just maybe to bring a
queen into the game with
instant checkmate but pretty much doing
anything will
will also win you the game uh so yeah
after rook captures an f8 wesley
resigned and uh it's really really
interesting because magnus spent so much
time so much time so much time in the
opening
uh uh when he played this rook debate he
was already
he had 10 minutes less than wesley
but this was a new move wesley didn't uh
uh
pick up the position as as quickly as he
kind of should have because wesley
really thrives in chaos like i said he
is the world rapid uh with the world
fish random champion uh so really really
uh interesting that magnus was able to
take this one
fairly easily 33 moves against wesley
that's that's
pretty awesome so we'll see if wesley is
able to bounce back
will we have a really crazy crazy match
or will this be a
a one-sided match as magnus already lost
the first two matches against wesley
so now if wesley wins the third one then
we really have to
you know we really have to question who
is the absolute best chess player in the
world so
magnus should really win one of them uh
but yeah uh once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it
i would like to thank rikishikilapiguchi
suresh kota mario
aditya kiran komanduri and dan dijong
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup finals
uh checking out your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day